it starts with the analyzing your
strength and weaknesses
and what are the growth areas you want
to aim
[Music]
thank you so much for being on 20 minute
leaders so gracious of you
yeah thanks for having me so we know
each other through a j ventures the
wonderful
uh early stage venture capital firm here
in silicon valley
and capitalistic books you're you're
very recently a venture
venture partner there nlp and the
screening committee
but besides that you have a ton of
experience
working with two incredible public
companies uh on growth and strategy
tower semiconductor are nice
and i'd love to spend this episode
talking about just that
strategy and growth and sort of the back
scenes of what drives these companies to
success
i love to uh share my experiences with
that uh
without opening and incredible so let's
just start
give me a little bit about yourself like
where are you from what excites you how
do you even get to do what you did
so grew up in israel as you can detect
from the accent
i moved here as part of a tower
semiconductor
when silicon valley was still about
silicon
and semiconductors and this was around
the silicon valley was was it actually
mainly about chips and silicon
it was all about chips a while back and
not too far
finally i get it yeah only three years
later okay amazing
uh so um this is after the standard
career
uh army and uh going to study the
technion and
starting some jobs uh in tech uh
and over here i spent some time running
tower usa
as president and vp marketing and uh
also uh in between tara and ice i had
stint as a consultant for six years
with early stage companies so i've
worked quite a bit with the
go to market strategies for the stage
companies of all
types right okay and it's just very
quickly go to market strategy
in two words what is it what does that
mean for you so
for the early stage staff it's something
that
uh many of the companies have typically
typically
need or they recognize need but they
don't have a defined
product necessarily or i find the how
you sell it
how you package it what is the product
is it a service is it
uh something tangible so even if they do
have a product it's not there's not
necessarily a strategy of how do you get
this product
to fulfill this need product market fit
in the in the textbooks but
it's a phase where you have to share
what you think with potential customers
uh and get feedback and at least hold on
your first version the minimum viable
product with with software it's easier
it's very easy to set up and test
when you involve the hardware or things
that are developed in the physical world
it's much tougher so
i did a lot of both more complicated
uh machines typically okay and and then
what is how do you go from from that to
you know growth
strategy m a because that's really the
next part of
of the life cycle of a startup right
yeah so
the way i look at it uh probably
strategy and m
a's are the least discussed uh
realities in the uh call it venture
ecosystem
uh when you look at it from the uh
startup side i'll start with that
statistically most startups would end
their life
in as part of an nmna if they are lucky
very few actually make it all the way to
an ipo
and many fall on the way but m a is a
big
piece of the outcome of a startup and
startups don't gear up and don't build
themselves
towards an m a and there is a
basically an art to how you do it right
we leave that for later in from a
company uh that is established point of
view
uh once you've uh crossed a certain
threshold and this is typically in the
already
multi-million dollar type revenue so
call it 10
15 20 and you start to grow
there's quite a bit of runway which you
could do by focusing
on what you set up the company to do
initially
right and then starts to be a more
strategic approach of growth
that could be coming out of uh
outside of your core how do you
accelerate
how do you address non-core either
features or markets
how do you respond to market changes how
do you head risks
and you get to the more creative side of
business development
which is either partnership strategic
partnerships co-development
and eventually m a's uh and in m
a's you are either being acquired or
being the acquirer
so hold on this is really this is really
complicated because what you're
essentially saying is
let's look at a life cycle of a startup
we're starting out we're running the
company we're controlling the product
we're the ones selling it
and then we reach a point in time where
we
are have we are making enough revenues
at 10 15 20 million
and we have to start making these
creative decisions of how
how do we position ourselves as key
players and how do we collaborate and
work with
potentially other key players either as
partnerships mergers or acquisitions
right so that is the
interesting phase of mind switch we're
not alone in this
now we're in the big players league and
we can actually work with others and
provide value to others
yeah that's exactly right the threshold
could vary quite a bit so
it could happen in 15 it could be
happening 150 but in order to cross the
billion and
the two companies that have had my
longest career runs uh with
are at one and a half billion dollar run
rate
right to get to the billion league uh
and this is in sales not in valuation
it's not the unicorn
billion it's the actual sales revenue
generating sales
per year you get a little bit more than
just your
initial momentum so you mean that was a
billion and a half
a years a year yearly revenue yeah
that's insane so you were essentially
helping lead growth and strategy
in two companies that are public and
they're generating over a billion
dollars in revenue a year so not
their market cap is a billion but
they're generating a billion in revenue
which means you have a lot of things you
can do you know and that's where you
come in
and that's where we come in so you
generate cash typically uh you
you get out of the cash starvation mode
right
but you still need to use it wisely and
you need to uh
make sure that every dollar you invest
brings you uh
much more than that dollar worth in in
future returns
what is that role strategy and growth
like how
how do you even work study for that and
prepare for that
so there is no official title for it
many mbas
would eventually end up doing pieces of
that
but uh the uh the the role is basically
something that you develop within big
corporations there's no
playbook or school to go to uh besides
gaining experience
and essentially every ceo business
leader that
is taking a company to that
journey of a billion dollar company
comes across the need for that
how you do it is different how you do it
is uh
could vary from one company to another
in a substantial way but
you want to get it right standing uh at
the core
what is your market what is your
strength and in like a very realistic
assessment
what you're missing and what you can get
better outside
uh which is the first part that's uh
what i call the easy part
and when i say easy it's still hard work
yeah you need to remember that for every
m a that happens out there there's
probably a 10 15 or 20 that you looked
at and you passed
for various reasons uh before you decide
to put the plug on a single m a
in a corporate uh and then comes the
hard part which is the
execution the integration into a big
company there's a lot of aspects to
consider
when you integrate cultural uh
work environments um just different
lexicon different lingo although you may
be in the same market
uh a lot of little details that
basically
uh are planned to guarantee that the mna
is eventually successful and stupid
okay so give me give me a couple of
those earned secrets from from your
experience in watching m as
and and different deals come about what
because a lot of them are nonstick not
successful right we hear all the time
of these different acquisitions who turn
out the the technologies didn't
integrate and the cultures were too
different or maybe financially was just
didn't make sense
what what can we how can we even start
to evaluate ahead of time
whether an m a will be successful or not
so first statistics in the big world
works against you it's similar to
startups really most m a's fail uh
yeah it depends who whose book you read
but uh
statistically beyond 50 fail or don't
achieve the original targets
wow uh and uh it does take
uh a lot of discipline and a lot of
planning to do it right
uh i believe that also you have to
consider
the uh post-merger activities with a lot
of
what you call eq emotional iq yes
and treat people in a way that uh
basically shows them the way in joining
a
bigger company there's a career
opportunity rather the end of the
journey and
a lot of startups are kind of uh call it
uh
triggered by the fact that when they
sell out it's the end of the journey
as opposed to a start of a new journey
which
is where some of the benefits could be
ripped by the bigger company so
of course unless you buy technology if
you want to buy
a business and continue to operate and
grow it
you have to uh keep the team motivated
you have to uh
get them into your family and you have
to uh learn how to
leverage each other's strengths
which is a very um in a way
it's a tough process for every human
being it's like
switching families well no i mean i and
and you see
the a lot of different extremes you see
some companies after they perform an
acquisition they keep the other company
as a separate entity completely
maintaining their culture and their dna
you see others that are absorbing them
and
bring them directly into their offices
and you know change your
from now on your company x before you
were why
is there is there now an insight into
how do you do that best or or is it a
case-by-case basis really
to me and this is uh coming from a
company that did mna's at the rate of
let's call it on average three or four a
year
uh there's no playbook per se
right just the case for the company and
it's also a case of you know the
acquirer who is the business owner that
gets to run the
acquisition and you know ideally you can
buy something and run it as a standalone
company if everything is perfect
right but it's not the only playbook if
you're talking about
serial acquirers people like cisco at
times
oracle salesforce uh they're more
operating based on playbooks
and cumulative history that is just
sheer numbers
uh but again i i do feel that when you
do a major acquisition when you go into
uh
something that is transformational and
i've done uh
i was involved in something like that at
a nice
uh you have to uh call it prepare
its own playbook you can just open a
generic one and say this is my way
interesting i want to go a little bit
back to growth because now i'm now i'm
asking for some personal tips
and i wish for myself that i'll get to a
position sooner rather than later that i
grow a startup that
that has made a positive impact has
generated revenue and now i'm at a
position
as in a leadership role where i can now
leverage
my new cash flow to grow the company and
to think
more broadly about how do we become a
key player what are some of the
key challenges or opportunities for a
young entrepreneur
who has never experienced this before
right you have a lot of ceos that all of
a sudden
fall into it they have a sas platform
that generates a lot of revenue
and now they have to make these
strategic decisions so how can i best
position myself
when i get to that position if i get to
that position to make the right decision
so it is quite call it
mundane when you talk about strategy
there's a
clear way of the working out a strategy
it starts with the analyzing your
strengths and weaknesses
and what are the growth areas you want
to aim right
uh you talk to customers all the time
this is something the ceo knows
very well how to do and when you talk to
customers
and actually listen to them not just
talk to them uh
and a startup ceo by the way they talk
first because they
they're used to selling more they're
educating the market a new thing
at a certain point in time you have to
start to listen
and uh pick up clues what's missing in
features what's missing in the
complementary product i've seen this
company doing a great job
that works together with your product
side by side
maybe you want to talk to them to see if
you can cooperate right now you have to
be very attentive to clues like that
in order to develop that what i call
non-organic strategy
and start to address you have to know
your market you have to know the
ecosystem you have to know what your
competitors are doing
and the role of that strategy function
or business development function is to
kind of collect all of these inputs
and roll them into a one coherent
strategy and a plan
okay so it's not so it's not just going
with your with your co-founders to the
beach
uh over over a weekend on a retreat
and then talking about some strata i'm
kidding of course but that's that's what
they show in the movies at least
and they're on i i also want to talk
because you're coming from israel and
one of the things that
you know a lot of people are are saying
you know the startup nation is fantastic
and there's so many great great
companies
and i've also heard the term exit nation
roll around
a few times and it seems like there is
sort of a different mentality
especially when it comes to this growth
and m a stage
between a lot of israeli companies and
companies that are
founded and based in the us do you also
see some difference or is there any
difference in mindset in that regard
i think there is a difference of mindset
and i there are many factors that could
be
attributed to that but first there is a
change in in the recent years you're
seeing
more companies break that call it
one billion dollar in sales ceiling and
getting uh
to be more common the things like that
would uh would happen
right uh but there is also an ecosystem
that you need to work with when you do
those m a's and strategic moves and this
is something that
uh could uh involved bankers
and investors
access to capital and sometimes in uh
the israeli ecosystem it's a very local
community they don't think as much
about that piece of the growth as the
u.s oriented bankers and
financial ecosystem around companies so
right
um it's not a an israeli mentality per
se you've got a lot of very good
israeli founders that do it here in a
different way
uh but the israeli ecosystem i don't
think is developed yet enough
to address all of these uh auxiliary
needs
okay serious thing you're thinking about
in the realm of the israeli ecosystem
which is
you know because you need a lot of
moving players to get to
a growth to get to a growth mindset and
to get
mindset in terms of your ability to
actually grow a company to that level
and get to an m a
and it's more about the maturity of all
the players around
not just the founders themselves
absolutely and and you've got very
sophisticated set of vcs which have that
call it 10 to 12 years runway mentality
and somebody needs to take it from there
and this is typically their private
equities or bankers
or other pieces of that ecosystem
fascinating i mean this is just also it
sounds like there's so many moving
pieces and it's and it's so much more
complicated
then just this say this you know this
young
and hardy notion of let's just create a
company and and grow to be a billion
dollars no you actually get to
to real stuff that you have to consider
a lot of moving pieces
and it's not just about the founder it's
not just about the company it's also
about your whole market and where you
position it
there what excites you what like you you
see so many companies you worked with so
many
what really excites you on the day today
so first uh
every time i see a new founder with a
new idea that kind of resonates with me
it excites it's exciting to get you
energized
just because you just identify with what
they are creating or about
besides that i i love to see a plan
come through okay i love to see a plan
that you put four or five or six years
ago
and all of a sudden you look back and
say it actually worked
it was a playbook wow and this is
something that is very very
satisfying and exciting i'm sure um
and besides that a deal every time
you're involved in a deal that's an
exciting phase
how many how many exciting deals would
you say you've been involved with
over the years uh i would say
probably it's probably not so fair
30. north of 30 deals
yeah some of them are small some of them
are bigger but yeah
wait wait wait wait wait wait drone
what's small what what's a small deal
small could be an acquisition that is an
aqui hire or technology acquisition that
you do just for
uh attacking uh typically you don't hear
about those
those are the uh typical quiet ones
and some of them could be much much
bigger much more involved
much more complicated i'm sure well you
know
just to give context i mean the majority
of people in the tech industry
especially
entrepreneurs and and tech executives
wish they would be a part of a single
great deal
throughout their lives so just uh why so
just listening to you i'm getting so
much
insight and seeing you've gone through
more than 30 deals whether they're big
or small i mean that's just
so inspiring they're on we only have a
just a few minutes left but
i i love to ask this last question
everybody and i'd love to know three
words that you would best use to
describe yourself
i'm especially curious i hear from
people of all industries
so what are your three words three words
uh one for sure would be foresight
foresight what does that mean explain
being able to look ahead
okay behind the curve
so foresight i would say you have to
have tenacity to last in
this industry do what i do and
the underrated one of all is team player
i think that's critical to be a team
player
you mentioned right before we started
the call that one of the things that you
that you are
very proud of is that a lot of the great
successes you've been a part of it's not
necessarily that you had to be you know
the founder the leader but
you sometimes you were the guy in the
back behind the scenes
that was really thinking things through
and allowing for the great deals to
happen
and and but but at the end you're a team
player that's how you identify yourself
which i think is beautiful
yeah a lot of business development guys
are in the shadows for
many many reasons but uh i've
i've met over my career some great ones
and
uh they're all able to foresee and
execute
i love it doron thank you so much for
the time thank you for the inspiration
and i'm just going to have to see you
around in the j ventures meetings
i can't wait to see you face to face
again thank you
take care
you